>> LAURA: IT IS TIME FOR OUR
FRIDAY FOLLY SEGMENT.
WE HAVE FANTASTIC STORIES TO
SHARE WITH YOU BUT FOR SOME NEWS
.
DEMOCRATS ARE LAUNCHING A
RELIGIOUS WAR OVER THE DEPARTURE
RELIGIOUS WAR OVER THE DEPARTUR
I'M GLAD THEY KNOW THERE IS A
HOUSE CHAPLAIN.
RAYMOND ARROYO HAS SOME
EXCLUSIVE DETAILS.
>> IT SHOULD'VE BEEN A SMALL
STORY.
FATHER PAT CONROY HAS BEEN THE
CHAPLAIN FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS.
HE WAS THE SECOND CATHOLIC
CHAPLAIN THE FIRST ONE.
>> IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> RIGHT, HOUSE OF
HE GAVE A PRAYER BEFORE THE TAX
VOTE AND SOME THOUGHT IT WAS A
PARTISAN CONTENT.
HE WAS MOVED BY PAUL RYAN
BECAUSE OF THE PRAYER.
THIS IS WHAT THEY SAID TODAY
THEY STORMED THE FORWARD
DEMANDING NOT ONLY AN
INVESTIGATION,  BUT WATCH.
>> THE DISMISSAL OF FATHER
CONROY SHOWS THE REPUBLICANS TO
REPUBLICAN STREET TO IN VALUE
BAIT AND CHARITY IN THE
LEGISLATIVE WORK.
THE RESULT THAT THERE IS HERE BY
THE RESULT THAT THERE IS HERE B
ESTABLISHED A SELECT COMMITTEE
TO INVESTIGATE THE ACTIONS AND
MOTIVATIONS BEHIND THE
RESIGNATION OF THE HOUSE
CHAPLAIN.
>> THEY BASICALLY WANT A SPECIAL
>> THEY BASICALLY WANT A SPECIA
CONSUL AGAINST PAUL RYAN.
NANCY PELOSI SAYS IT'S UNJUST, I
NANCY PELOSI SAYS IT'S UNJUST,
SPOKE TO A NUMBER OF MEMBERS
TODAY.
>> FREEMAN WAS ON THE PHONE WITH
>> FREEMAN WAS ON THE PHONE WIT
FOUR MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ONE
DEMOCRAT, THREE REPUBLICANS.
>> SOME OF THEM COMPLAINED TO
PAUL RYAN HIMSELF.
ONE TOLD ME FATHER WAS A LITTLE
MORE PARTISAN THAN PASTOR.
OTHERS SAID THEY WENT TO HIM FOR
OTHERS SAID THEY WENT TO HIM FO
COUNSELING AND THOUGHT HE WASN'T
COUNSELING AND THOUGHT HE WASN'
AS WARM OR UNDERSTANDING AS HE